oh my Matt what do you know about
childbirth what do you know about
childbirth well a whole lot actually and
I've studied it in school
we're here because of it I've witnessed
a Kardashian birth how did the
Kardashian birth which just happens like
regular human birth have you ever seen
an animal being born Oh No
would you be interested in seeing yes
hold this night I'd like to do I would
love to see that whole bed you're gonna
show as a child boom boom yeah well an
animal child are you gonna give me some
facts about it also
I trust you 0% yeah you should not at
all it's rough birth great should we
narrate ok so there's a giraffe lots of
oh my god oh my god there's a thing
coming out of the giraffes potholes the
mother giraffe is standing up which is
to be applauded oh yeah here's some
strange sounds
yeah it's dangling it's falling out it's
it's an amazing thing I'm sad you just
yelled at us we got to keep it down
elephant elephant here we go now how
many times have you seen this
that is horrible oh my god it's so
pretty is heavy that's how babies are
made
that's not exactly how I would have
expected it not like the Kardashian
birth a little different well I wasn't
so bad right it was pretty bad no closer
to me I think yeah we could we could
talk about stuff yeah have you seen
videos of sea horses have you seen
videos of them having over this is
really beautiful though this is
different I think you're gonna be amazed
oh my god oh my god oh my god yeah I
know shooting them out repeatedly this
is unbelievable I've never seen anything
like this I came here to show you animal
childbirth you showed me whoa yeah
somebody said thank you
[Music]